all right this is what I do remember and
you're gonna be like really that's what
you remember and I stole this from you
on my show good you used to do a thing
where and you would do this in like like
a very obviously jokey way and everyone
loved it someone would off no no
you would say go yourself like
literally somebody somebody would say
hey Michael can you uh stand on your
mark and be like yeah go yourself
and I just thought it was so funny and
then the crew would do it with me yeah
I'd say hey can you make sure that yeah
yourself let's just yeah it was a
thing we all did it and I just thought
you do it you did it on vampire I became
known as the go yourself even as
rap gifts they gave the crew
gfy hats from me which was and you never
called me go yourself hats I
literally stole that from you did you
ever tell anybody nobody told any I
never told anyone until
I'm on a podcast right now telling the
world that I still go yourself from
you